in minneapolis derek shovin's murder
trial resumes this morning after a day
of dramatic
and sometimes traumatic eyewitness
testimony
yesterday prosecutors played police body
camera footage for the jury
more than one hour of video in all
witnesses testified that they felt
guilty about george floyd's death and
wish they could have helped him
jamie yukas is outside the courthouse in
minneapolis jamie how are the jurors
reacting to this testimony
well adriana one juror had to take a
break as nearly
every witness burst into tears on the
stand she told the judge she had a
stress related reaction felt shaky
and has had trouble sleeping prosecutors
also introduced
new never before seen videos as evidence
again we want to warn you
this video is disturbing 61-year-old
charles mcmillan was one of the first
people on the scene may 25th
he said he was trying to make the
situation easier for george floyd
with officer myself and i understand
once you get in
the cup you can't win when derek chauvin
arrived on the scene mcmillan who often
walks the neighborhood
said he recognized him from a few days
earlier i see
mr sharp and i told him like i tell our
officer at the end of the day
you go home and your family's safe and
that the next person go home today
family safe
mcmillan broke down when prosecutors
showed body camera footage of floyd
being pinned to the ground
stop moving mama
mama
after the ambulance left the scene that
day mcmillan confronted chauvin
and for the first time we can clearly
hear chauvin
kind of control this guy because he's a
sizable guy
looks like he's probably on something
the jury also saw
new security video of floyd in the cup
food store
where he allegedly used what appeared to
be a counterfeit 20-dollar bill
christopher martin is the cashier who
interacted with floyd
i seem to just be having average
memorial day just
living his life but it did seem high
later you can see martin outside the
store with his hands on his head
what was going through your mind during
that time period disbelief
thank you why guilt if i would have just
not taken the bill this could have been
avoided the neighborhood where the cup
foods is located
is still healing in the months since
floyd's death what's this space been
like since the trial started we've gone
through
a myriad of emotion marcia howard is a
veteran and one of the minneapolis
residents who's a caretaker of 38th and
chicago
a barricaded protest zone george perry
floyd jr was a real person
not simply a symbol we all know that
that trial
somehow seems to be
a trial of the value of a black life
these streets
are to remain closed until the
conviction of all four
officers who killed george floyd will be
on barricades
no justice no street
the cup foods cashier you saw testify
was not the one to call the police
but he did tell his manager he thought
the bill was fake
witness after witness has mentioned the
guilt they feel for not doing more
to save george floyd gail everybody who
witnessed it that day feels guilty i
can't imagine what the jury is thinking
watching this it's very tough thank you
jamie very much